Noah Baumbach's "Marriage Story" is less
about marriage than it is about divorce,
depicting the souring of what started as
an amicable split between an actress and
her theater-directing husband. Like 69%
of divorces in the United States, the wife
initiated the separation. We learned
that she felt oppressed in her marriage,
believing that her career and ambitions
were consumed by those of her husband.
But the marriage was fairly egalitarian
by modern sensibilities, with both
husband and wife working and sharing
domestic responsibilities. This gets at
what is one of the most important social
issues shown in the film, though likely
not Baumbach's intention. Studies show
that women on the whole seem to have
lower satisfaction rates with their
marriages than men. Even after decades of
men doing more housework and more
childcare, and women spending more time
on their careers,
many women seem no happier than
a half-century ago, and maybe even less so.
Maybe it's that society has created
unrealistic expectations for women.
Marriage not only means finding
a soul mate and a helpful father and a breadwinner,
it is also an exercise in self-fulfillment.
Did you think the movie "Marriage Story" was
an accurate depiction of marriage today?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.